we're joined now by the head of personal
finance at AJ Bell Laura Suter Laura
hello to you let's go through some of
the findings that have come out today
there's so much new information about
the uh economy out there at the moment
let's drill into these um unemployment
figures first the new data showing that
the UK's unemployment figures had fallen
to its lowest rate in decades can you
put this into context and explain the
significance and importance of this yeah
of course so if we look at this is the
unemployment rate going all the way back
to the 1970s on what it shows at this
end which is the current day is that
it's dropped significantly so we're at a
lowest rate for almost 50 years it's 3.5
which usually is a very good thing
that's usually a positive thing however
what we're seeing at the moment if we go
on to this next slide is this red line
here shows the number of vacancies so
the number of companies trying to hire
at the moment with job vacancies and the
blue line is the number of unemployed
people in the UK now if we look very at
the end here they've crossed over which
effectively means there's more vacancies
than there are people to fill them and
that obviously presents an issue for
companies but also for the economy yeah
so that looks like that's going to be an
ongoing issue can we talk about
um people that are economically inactive
and why that is what's the story behind
the stats yeah so it's a it's not a very
catchy phrase but um effectively there's
three groups of people people that are
in employment so that have jobs people
that are unemployed but they're looking
for work and then the economically
inactive which are people that are out
of work but they're not looking to get
into work and that could be for a
variety of reasons and what we see here
so um over nearer you is that economic
inactivity rate that you can see is
ticked up a bit towards the end and here
we have the age breakdown of the people
that are economically inactive and what
we've seen is there's been a big rise in
the number of younger people who've been
economically inactive and then more
recently over here on the this side
we've seen more of that older generation
being economically inactive and that's
kind of largely down to two reasons for
younger people it's more of them going
into higher education more students and
then particularly around the pandemic
there were fewer opportunities to go
into the job market so more people
stayed in education but then also this
blue line is what's concerning that's
the long-term sick and we can see this
big increase here and that's actually
the the highest on record for the number
of long-term sick that are economically
inactive at the moment and that's the
figure that's particularly worrying at
the moment okay
um what are the wider implications of
all of this then when you put them all
together yeah so if we go to this next
slide which has lots of colors on it but
um this shows the breakdown of people
that are on Universal Credit and it
shows whether they're in work and this
big red chunk here is people that are no
work required so that's people that have
been assessed for Universal Credit and
it's been deemed that they can't work so
that could be due to long-term sickness
that we talked about or caring for
people that are long-term sick and what
we can see is that's increased
dramatically so that has a big impact
for people's personal finances because
they're reliant on Universal Credit but
also on the government's finances
because that's a large chunk of people
that won't be going back into work that
are on Universal Credit okay Laura thank
you and really interesting just putting
those figures into some kind of context
for us today a lot of new information
out there we're breaking it down for you
here on Sky News